I've admired your joke writing over the
years you write terrific
jokes and and you are constantly
tinkering with them you you're not
satisfied and so you get it just right
sometimes like ten years I've worked on
our job yeah my mom would come out and
torture me and my brother and go what do
you think I got this outfit for and we
would go you're ruining our lives
no and we would I would go 900 and my
mom would go Louie so for years I did
that joke in there one time I did the
joke I'm on stage I go cuz that's not
the right punch line right there have
you had the area set up and my mom comes
out and she goes what do you think I got
this outfit for I go Halloween it really
took that long dead Wow can I just tell
you one personal thing yeah when I my
brother was very ill and we were out on
the 3rd or Beverly Boulevard I was
sitting in a car talking to him and I
said hey will you say hi to my brother
and you talked to him oh that's right I
have 10 or 20 minutes and I made the
biggest difference in his wife
well my brother Roger God rest his soul
so that was really nice video
oh no I'm happy to do it I my wife is
usually when people stop us on the
street and talk to me and I will go I'll
talk and then there's sometimes I'll
just like pull up a chair and I can tell
they want to go mayor chimney Conan's
going on a little long here
you